[Applause]
so I'm going to start with our auditors
I spent a lot of time thinking about
religious symbolism and archetypes but
there's a service the problem with that
and the problem is its lacks
concretization you know to think about
the ultimate ideal is only something
that's symbolic it moves away from the
real world it's partly for this reason
that there's an insistence in
Christianity that the logos of two
things at once
it took me a long time to figure this
out and I was guided in my attempts to
understand it by Carl Jung who was a
truly remarkable person and probably
orthodoxy his fundamental conviction so
I would say he talked about the logos as
the thing that's existed at the
beginning of time and this is a very
particular way of looking at things for
the idea is essentially that a Jonathan
pointed out was deaf
there's something about consciousness
that's called forth being from chaotic
potentials and if you all understand
what this means because when you look at
the future or if you look at yourselves
you know that what you confront is a
field of potential and everyone tells
you that they tell you you're not living
up to your potential and put this is a
very strange thing because it doesn't
yet exist and so by the canons of say
modern time not something that has any
reality whatsoever but everyone knows
precisely what it it means and
everything around me was closed
potential because you can interact with
them to bring forth new things and you
know that and you can be called for your
failure to do it and you eat
ecole you cope yourself for your failure
to do it because you wake up at 3 in the
morning and you torture yourself with
your inability to bring forth the
potential discontinuance and haunts your
soul and in a challenge and the reason
it tellers is because it is talents and
if you don't call forth the potentials
that within you and outside of you then
the world does transform you to hell
because that's a candidacy anyway and
we've had no shortage of evidence of
that in the last 400 years it's part of
the Christian doctrine that at the
beginning of time
the logos of yahwah awfully long
potentially brought for habitable the
habit of the world order and it was
perfect in some strange sense it was the
paradise in which out in the knees were
placed in the paradise with its walled
garden a well watered places the walled
garden is a place of order and chaos
culture and nature enough because people
inhabit a garden of culture nature that
that's our environment and if those two
properties are properly balanced then
inside that garden everyone can flourish
and human beings are principle made in
the image of that logo and that's why we
can see things being and we do and when
you see truth then you speak paradise
into being and when you speak falsely
detailing the a and that's the truth and
what that means is that with every
decision that you make you decide for
yourself and for everyone else whether
you're going to tilt the world a little
bit more toward L or a little bit more
towards heaven and that's the burden you
bear for your existence and the choices
that you make as you passed through life
and it's the fleeing from that it's at
the bottom of the nihilism of
post-modernism and the occasion to the
totalitarian certainties of title
worship
and none of this is fictional because
we've seen the consequences Jonathan
said 14 I don't remember the sort that
there could be no poetry after Oxford
but that's wrong but the poetry has to
be about Auschwitz the lesson for Marx
which was never again and fair enough so
you you can't decide not to repeat
something terrible unless you understand
it and the way to understand it is that
the small things of each individual
culminated the great students of the
state and since when you ask why
terrible things happen in the world the
answer is quite simple the answer is
because you're not good enough and it's
because you don't tell the truth and you
know it Jonathan says something I
thought was very interesting it's
something I thought about but I haven't
taught them about it at all what happens
as you move towards the truth and answer
is everything comes together it really
that really is the answer is everything
comes together there's even a sexual
element to that because of course the
highest element of sexual ecstasy is to
come together and around someone who's
telling the truth everything comes
together and that's the potential
destiny of the world it's something that
you can partake in it's the call it's a
call to the greatest adventure that
there is you can bring forth something
again to paradise by seeking the truth
and you can start in your own life and
you can started in the life of your own
families and these are people in
principle that you love until why would
you do anything that speaks the truth to
them to protect them from reality
there's no protecting anyone from
reality reality just is you interact
with it on your to own its terms
can you do that my favorite sport right
late and you do that by not shying away
from the challenge I spent a lot of time
trying to understand the Sermon on the
Mount
it's a very strange document I'm going
to tell you what I think it means it
means conceptualize the highest religion
camp and so you might think that would
be the highest food for you and it would
be the highest good for the family
around you that you love it would be the
highest with that family in the state
and he'd be the highest rate for the
state in the world and that would be the
highest possible would aim at that even
though you don't know how aim is that
make that what you want and then tell
the truth and it's an adventure because
you don't know what's going to happen
you have no idea because it increases
incidentally if you treat people
instrumental you use them as tools for
your own desire and not the problem with
that is what do you know about what you
desire
many things that you chase will turn out
to be empty well what happens if you
just tell the truth
well the world will unfold around you in
very strange in the serious ways and
there isn't anything that's more
exciting than that is it perhaps
something exciting enough so that it's
suffering that the tendons on being
would redeem itself by God adventures
and that's the call that the Western
calls in the individual the suffering of
beings and redeem itself through truth
and it's not it's not a rule it's not a
proposition that you need to adhere to
like a good citizen if it's the proper
way of lending your way through the
terrible world without making it worse
than it already is with the possibility
for houses making it better there's no
more exciting possibilities than that
and no higher moral demand because the
thing is is everyone knows that you know
when you lie according to your own
conception of the truth that there's
something something shameful and
demeaning about that and you know that
it hurts people and you think well why'd
you do it despite all that in part is to
do it because it's easy and partly do
you do it because there's
crooked horrible hellish part of the
soul that's more than happy as part of
what to do is make everything worse to
pay for the sin of its existence and I
would say we should stop doing that and
see what we can do it was not ourselves
together because human beings are
remarkable creatures we put together an
amazing civilization working out at half
time you know it's like 55 percent of
humanity on a good days working to make
things better 45% is working to make it
worse and you wonder what would happen
if we all just decided that we were
going to make things better as simple as
that start where you are make things
around you better where would we be what
would the world turn into around a
civilization of people who are genuinely
trying to make things better I can tell
you we better find out soon because if
we don't try collectively to make things
better given the current state of
affairs they are going to get a lot
worse I thought for a long time I wonder
why people find themselves adrift in
meaninglessness there's a lot of answers
to that there's a classical criticisms
of traditional faith that has been put
forth by brilliant even like Friedrich
Nietzsche there's the idea that that
there were fairytales that people live
by prior to the modern age and we no
girl knows and that's leftist in a
cosmos disparate of meaning and so it's
a consequence of the inevitable
unfolding of a kind of cutting
rationality and some of that truth but
there's a lot of it it isn't true you
know because I've also come to
understand that the reason that so many
of us proclaim that life is meaningless
is because we actually would rather have
it be meaning less than to take
responsibility for it because you can
imagine this and imagine this scenario
imagine you were offered a choice and
this is because you are all this choice
if you say well absolutely nothing you
do matters and through the help in the
null waiting waves in the million years
and so you can do whatever you want
moment to moment right now
so pay off for that perspective and you
can do whatever you want moment moment
and you'll not be held responsible by
anyone in urging yourself or pursuing
your any impulsive immoral foolish
destructive genocide 'el tendencies or
the alternative is that you can assume
that everything you do is meaningful and
everything you do has an impact on the
way the world unfold and taking
responsibility for that and you know
it's something that you'll have your
meaning alright that's for sure because
you have an infinite amount of
responsibility for every decision that
you make under those circumstances and
perhaps as a medicaments for that the
knowledge that when you're on the path
properly that you're helping youth world
unfold in the best direction that it's
often we could well there isn't anything
better than that if you want something
to set against the inevitable suffering
of life that's what you said against it
the endless adventure of trying to make
things better in every possible way and
god only knows where we get if we did
that around the perfect man everything
comes together and I don't believe that
that's that that's where the infinite
logos that express that stretches across
time and space comes together in a
single individual that's the Christian
story the reason for that is this every
single person is embedded in a specific
time and place that's you as an
individual but at the same point you're
also the embodiment of this thing that
has acted across forever to call chaos
into habitable B you're both divine
eternal transcendent essence and the
finite shell that you inhabit it's like
a genie right a genius genius and the
genie is something that can grasp three
magical wishes but how
have this tiny little space it's the
same idea well you can act that out in
your life and you can transcend it and
as you do that things come together
around you and everything becomes
musical that's the right way to think
about it and everything becomes a lie
and you shy away from that because
you're resentful of us the fundamental
structure is being and you don't want
the responsibility and it's no bloody
wonder because the responsibility is the
responsibility for everything
you know that's why it's hard as it
Kristen sorry the crisis into the world
of autumn fell because that's what you
have to do in order to put yourself
together it's your fault everything it
isn't going right is because you're not
good enough well who wants that right
welcome the postmodernist
has they'll lighten the burden the
consequences if nothing has any meaning
but that's a small price to pay it's
really that particular burden
well maybe not maybe the meaning of life
is to be found in your voluntary
willingness to take on that burden and
carry it right well that's the notion
that's embedded in the idea of the cross
right pick up a full conscious knowledge
of your own vulnerability your your
subjugation to betrayal your carrier
your slavery at the hands of the states
your insanity and your mortality and to
say I'll bear that voluntarily it's okay
I can handle it
it seems to me that we're at a kind of
crossroads I don't know exactly why you
always meet the devil at the crossroads
by the way and the reason set out is
because every crossroads is a choice
right and it's always a choice between
good and evil to me we're at a
crossroads and I don't know why I guess
it's because the terrible 20th century
is standard energy and now we have
something new in the aftermath of that
it's time for everyone to pick up the
chaotic pieces and carry them
voluntarily and to make their way
through the world and to try to each
their turn and to see what happens it
will heal yourself will heal your body
will heal your soul healing your family
it'll heal the nation that returns and
how could it be any other way
the reality is the truth and how are you
going to adapt to it without anything
too true
well the problem is reality is the
terrible truth but it's certainly
possible the terrible truth is its own
medicine with regards to my connection
orthodoxy I have kind of a funny story
to tell about tough love 15 years ago a
student of mine who has maintained the
relationship with since I taught it at
Harvard I'd helped him through a
difficult period he his family has been
at the center of a real storm of
publicity posters a front page story for
a number of moon ha recently we returned
the favor with me but he proposed at one
point that I fly down to Los Angeles and
acts as the mission of his marriage and
I thought and so I thought well if I'm
going to do that I better get ordained
because that's obviously the logical
thing to do and I thought well how do
you get ordained going short notice and
that's obviously the answer to that if
you go online so happy
so I went online and I signed up I could
name my church so I did I have this
church I'm the only member
the called this is called the Church of
the spirit of st. yochem explora which
you know isn't in Surrey the name that
he would expect
I like safe guilt him from what I knew
of him because he had this idea that
there were three he thought there would
be three he thought to Western
civilization and one would be the epoch
of the Father next draft of the Old
Testament epoch an Old Testament
morality that has to be with following
rules and then there was the epoch of
the Sun and that was of course equal the
Christian epoch of the last 2,000 years
and he believed in what would come after
that would be part of the Holy Ghost and
the Holy Ghost is this weirdest hereís a
that hypothetically Christ left behind
didn't have the people and guide them on
their path and it seems to me that
that's very much in keeping with the
orthodox idea that the proper moral
pathway for each individual to take is
to attempt to bear the burden of the
perfect individual right to become
Christ so to speak in an attempt to
transcend mortality and finitude into
and to unite this rod and I thought well
that was kind of a cool idea so I
thought well I might as well have that
in church and then I thought who should
I be in this church and I thought well
Pope was probably a little bit on the
North Pacific side let's say so I
thought I'll be metropolitan if I
thought that was kind of archaic in
Athens and sort of out of the way enough
so that it was a good joke so I'm my own
messes all in my own church it only has
one rule and so you can join it if you
want the rule is that if you're a member
of my church you can't follow stupid
rules
yeah so that's a good rule because it's
actually him it's an ante rule rule a
which is really funny as far as I'm
concerned anyway I went down to LA and I
didn't marry these two and they're still
married and so that's good and yeah yeah
so I know that's a good family but it's
been a long day
I talked to Sam Harris today again for
those of you who it went great
yeah it went great anyway so look if the
idea of pretty straight forward you know
as far as I can tell there's this
tremendous idea that's at the bottom of
Western cultures have taken human race
millennia and perhaps an endless amount
of time before then an eternal amount of
time before then to formulate and the
ideas that are consciousness and that's
the center of us the soul whatever that
happens to be partakes in the process by
which creation comes into being and we
do that through the logos which is our
capacity to think and to other words and
to engage in dialogue but more
importantly to do that truthfully and
that's to the degree that we're able to
do that truthfully we bring paradise
into being rather than hell and it seems
to me this F as opposed to objective
reality although it's not precisely
objective it's more than objective
reality it's a kind of meta realities
it's the most profound truth that you'll
ever encounter and the thing that's cool
about it is you can even come you can
put it to the test if you want you know
you start deciding that you're not going
to lie because how the hell are you
going to tell the truth well you know
you don't know what the truth is like
you certainly know when you lie and you
know how to stop doing that so I would
say we'll just try stop lying and see
what happens try it for like a year you
don't get to lie about anything anymore
and that also means you can't do things
that you would be afraid to talk about
because you know if you're going to tell
the truth you have to tell the truth
about what you did and if you do
reprehensible things then you can't just
run around telling everybody about them
so it also means that you have to not
act in a way that you would be
truthfully about and try it we find out
first of all that you're so full of lies
and deceit that you just [ __ ] well
can't believe it when I started doing
this 30 years ago it really just about
drove me crazy just divided into two
people in some sentence one person one
person was talking and the other person
was watching the person that was talking
and the talking person sort of puppet
and the watching person was the right
person
everytime the talking person said so and
to watch in person to go kill bleep that
is
true that isn't your idea and I thought
wow that's really not good because it
looks like 95% of what I'm saying isn't
mine or I'm saying it for show or and
say if you walnut primate or I'm saying
it so that I can be you know so that I
can use my language instrumentally and
get what I want or you know I swiped it
from a book and I really don't deserve
it but I'm saying it was horrible with
95% seriously and so then I learned that
means a part and only say things that
made me feel like I was together and
that part of that coming together you
can feel that physically you know with
you if you say something to people you
shrink and you power from it it makes
you embarrassed and it makes you weak
you can feel the weakness like well good
stop saying things that make you weak if
you don't want to be nice if you want to
be strong stop saying things that makes
you feel weak try it and try it see what
happens you can test this out and year
things will be way different for you and
five years you won't even be the same
person god only knows what will happen
in the decade so it's really worth it
besides you don't have anything better
to do anyway because here you are
you know suffering stupidly away might
as well get something useful with your
time while you're waiting to die so and
there isn't anything more interesting to
do than that it's so cool because I mean
it's part of what I decided to do last
September when I may be you know crazy
videos which really have more than
effects and I certainly thought they
would I thought well I got some things
to say and why don't I say them and see
what happens
that's an excellent way to live why
don't I say the things that I think and
see what happened
well this is one of the things that's
happened so that's kind of cool I mean
how are likely is it completely absurd
and ridiculous here I was Jonathan this
crazy parentheses are going to guides
and directors here I mean exactly that's
exactly what you'd expect given what I
can talking about recently very unlikely
and all just to be very unlikely and
life is very enlightening you know maybe
it could be absolutely magnificent
wonderful we could make everything into
a holy temple in which we could live
forever peacefully only searching for
more remarkable and spectacular things
to do next and that's what people do in
Paradise they sit around dreaming about
how the paradise they already have could
give rise to a paradise that yes greater
than the one that's there and with the
collective imagination that we pursue
that could be a never ending thing and
we can bring it into being adapt Alicia
to because the alternative is to let
everything degenerating to chaos and
hail and how about we don't do that
[Applause]